はじめん！今日も頑張ろうパパね～
バーバぱぱ
ありがとう．．．
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです
いまぁボクの口はましゅい（麻酔）がきいてます
そもそも麻酔って何なのかよくわからないんですけど
とりあえず今こっちのこっちの感覚が全くないです
パ、パ、パ
全然殴ってもいたくない
ヤヴァイヤヴェーどしｔエエエ
ほんと困ってるんすしゅよね
あの実はなんですけど
去年歯医者に通ってて
虫歯があって
もう途中から忙しくなっちゃって
歯医者に通えなくなってしまいましゅた
で！
今日久しぶりに時間があったんで行ってきたんですけども
そりゃそうですよ　虫歯、一本だった虫歯が二本になってて
麻酔、なんか２発くらい打たれて
じゃ、治療して行きますねって言われて　キュイーンってされるんですけど
MAJIDE
「痛かったら左手上げて下さい」って言われたんでもう、
キューインってきた瞬間すぐピッって上げたて
もう、やべ、日本語もうまく喋れねーや
もう一本麻酔打とうかって言われて
強力な何か麻酔を打たれて今に至ります
すごいんすよ！麻酔っていうのは
例えばここに牛乳があるとしましょう
この牛乳すらを飲む事すらも
ちょっとままならないレベルだと思う
いただきます
ん”ん”
んーんーんーんーんーごふふｗ
ごふふｗごふふｗ
なんかもう本当にこっちの力が入んなくて
ぶううううううぶううううぶうう
だめだもうふくれっ面もできない
？？？
頬っぺた膨らますこともできないんですよ
こっちが何か力　入んないから、開いちゃうんです
ズビ．．．
ツラ(´;ω;｀)
あの、今我慢してるんですけど
今も痛いんですよ
何か多分これ麻酔きれると超痛いやつです
今まだ麻酔の力で何とかごまかしてるわけなんですけど
多分もじきするとすごい痛みがくるんで
僕は死にます
ほんとにマジで歯医者は行ったほうがいいですよ
ボクマジで歯医者通おうかと思ってますもん、今
わかめご飯とか食べれるかな
どれほどの歯へのダメージがあるかわからないんですけどちょっと一回食べてみます
こっち側怖くて噛めない
え。。。だいじょぶ？
まって多分ほんとに超強力な麻酔が今かかってるんで、うまく噛めない
ほっちがはなんはほっちがは（こっち側何かこっち側）
クッキングパパみたいになってるわけですねこうやって
困った困った
つねったりしても何かそんな他人ごとみたいな痛さですね
どんぐらいだろう今日多分普通に歯医者いって
３時にスタートして終わったのは５時だから
２時間以上の治療してました
ワーオ❤
まって！
麻酔が切れてきた
麻酔が切れてきたぞお
はあああああ（苦）
ひいいいいいい（苦）
牛乳って飲んでいいのかな。ってかダメだった気がするな
あ。。。
ダメだー
抗生物質だもんねだって
抗生物質こそ牛乳と飲んだらダメみたいらしいです
ちょっと。。。バイバイ
まってまってホントにマジでいたい歯茎が、ヤヴァイ
ハウッ！
食後三十分。一個でいいのかな？
食後三十分一錠
ロキソニンだ、よくあるやつだ
これを俺は一日三食朝昼晩に飲まなきゃいけません
薬でい（？）
はっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはやくっはっ薬を！はっは
すぅー
はあはあはあはあはー
イタイ(´・ω・｀)
みんなホント ちょっと歯がおかしいと思ったらすぐに歯医者に行ってください
死ぬほど痛い思いをしてしまいます
しばらく歯医者通います
では☆
んぺんぺんぺんぺんぺんぺんぺ、
ぺーぺぺぺぺーぺーぺぺぺぺーぺぺぺぺぺぺーぺぺぺぺーぺーぺぺぺぺぺーぺーぺー
んぺんぺんぺんぺ
ぺぺぺぺん（ゲシュタルト崩壊した）
この川
深いっ！